GIVING HIM AN INFRASTRUCTURE
WIN.
JOINING ME NOW NEWT GINGRICH AND
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN.
NEWT, SOME GOP MEMBERS IT SEEMS
LIKE THEY DON'T WANT TO WIN BACK
CONGRESS SUPPORTING THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
GOING TO 4 TRILLION DOLLARS.
>> WELL, I THINK SOME OF THE
REPUBLICANS TEND TO TAKE A SHORT
TERM WIN AND FORGET THE LARGEST
GAIN.
THEY FEEL GOOD.
THEY HAVE BEEN BIPARTISAN.
THEY ARE GETTING SOMETHING DONE.
THE THING THEY ARE GETTING
DONE -- AS YOU POINTED OUT, THEY
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IS IN THE
BILL.
THEY HAVE NO VETO OVER WHAT IS
IN THE BILL.
THEY WILL GET A BILL WHICH IS
DRAMATICALLY WORSE THAN ANYTHING
THEY AGREED TO.
THEY WILL HAVE NO ABILITY TO
CHANGE IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE A DISASTER.
THERE IS A WING OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHICH IS THE
WING THAT REAGAN OPPOSED AND THE
WING WE OPPOSED WHEN I WAS
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
IT'S A WING WHICH SAYS YOU
ALWAYS HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO BE
RESPONSIBLE.
BEING RESPONSIBLE MEANS SELLING
OUT TO THE LEFT.
THESE 17, MANY ARE GOOD FRIENDS
AND I HAVE RESPECT FOR THEM BUT
THEY GOT SUCKERED ON.
THIS IT'S THE WRONG THING TO DO.
THEY OUGHT TO RETHINK ENOUGH.
MORE THAN ENOUGH REASON TO VOTE
AGAINST THE BILL WHEN THEY SEE
THE BILL.
THEY HAVE NOT SEEN THE WRITTEN
LANGUAGE.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM TO DECIDE
THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
I DON'T THINK I CAN GO ALONG
WITH IT.
>> Laura: IT'S 2700 PAGES LONG
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
SENATOR CASSIDE SAID HE READ IT.
THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE A SPEED
READER.
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN, SOME
REPUBLICANS INCLUDING A FELLOW
FROM OHIO, WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE?
IT'S OBVIOUS THIS IS A 2-FER.
IT'S NOT INFRASTRUCTURE ON ITS
OWN.
>> RIGHT.
ONLY 10% OF THE BILL IS DEVOTED
TO INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT IS IN THE BILL IS THE WORD
EQUITIES MENTIONED OVER 60
TIMES.
IN ALL OF THE TIME THAT SPEAKER
GINGRICH WAS IN CONGRESS HE
NEVER SAW A INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
FOCUSSED ON EQUITY.
IT'S A BUNCH OF LEFT WING
SPENDING AND THE DEMOCRATS CRAZY
ECONOMIC PLAY.
LOCK DOWN ECONOMIES AND PAY
PEOPLE NOT TO WORK AND FOR THOSE
WHO ARE WORKING THEY WILL RAISE
YOUR TAXES.
THIS IS BAD.
WHAT THE REPUBLICANS ARE
THINKING, I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S STEP 1 OF A BIGGER SPENDING
BILL COMING LATER.
YOU POINTED THIS OUT LAST NIGHT
IN YOUR INTERVIEW.
THIS IS PART OF THE CRAZY
ECONOMIC PLAN.
I THINK IT'S WHY WE ARE GOING TO
WIN.
THE ELECTION IS NOT TODAY BUT
IT'S NEXT YEAR.
I THINK WE WILL WIN AND TAKE
BACK THE HOUSE.
>> Laura: NEWT, YOU GIVEAWAY
SOME AUTHORITY IF THE WISE MEN
IN YOUR PARTY AND WOMEN TOO ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO GIVE BIDEN THIS
WIN ON INFRASTRUCTURE AND GLIDE
RIGHT INTO 3.5-TRILLION DOLLARS
OF FAMILY MEDICAL LEAVE AND
BANKRUPTING A FUTURE GENERATION.
THIS IS INSANE?
>> I AM EMBARRASSED TO BE CALLED
A REPUBLICAN WHEN THEY ARE
WANTING IT.
>> LOOK.
THERE IS THE KIND OF BEHAVIOR
WHICH LED TO THE RISE OF THE TEA
PARTY FROM PEOPLE WHO WERE
FURIOUS AT THE FAILURE OF
WASHINGTON LEADERSHIP.
IT LED TO 63% DISAPPROVAL OF
REPUBLICAN LEADERS IN THE
CONGRESS JUST BEFORE DONALD
TRUMP RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
PEOPLE LOOK AT THIS AND THINK
WHAT IS THE PLAN?
WHY DO WE RACE THE MONEY AND GO
OUT TO VOTE?
WE ARE GETTING PEOPLE SUCKERED
IN.
I DON'T MIND IF THEY CAN'T PLAY
CHESS, BUT IF THEY CAN'T PLAY
TIC-TAC-TOE SOMETHING IS WRONG.
AT THEIR LUNCHEON THIS IS
ANYTHING AND SHOULD BAIL ON IT.
IT WILL BE WORSE THAN THEY
THINK.
THE 2700 PAGES WILL BE FOLLOWED
BY 50,000 PAGES OF REGULATIONS.
THERE IS MORE THAN ENOUGH REASON
FOR THOSE 17 SENATORS TO DECIDE
THEY GOT SUCKERED AND THE TIME
HAS COME TO KILL IT AND NOT MOVE
IT FORWARD.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN GORDON,
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SEE HOW A
FORMER OBAMA STRATEGIST IS
DESCRIBING THIS.
>> IT'S A ONE SIDED MASSACRE OF
ANTI-TRUMPERS.
YOU ARE SEEING IT IN THIS
BIPARTISANS INFRASTRUCTURE
STEAL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP THE LEADER OF
OUR PARTY.
AMERICANS APPRECIATE HE DID WHAT
HE SAID HE WOULD DO WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHY WE WILL WIN.
THESE GUYS HAVE DONE SO MANY
CRAZY THINGS.
CRIME AND INFLATION AND THE
CRISIS ON THE BORDER.
THAT'S WHY WE WILL WIN.
PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED WITH THESE
GUYS AND THEY WILL PUT
REPUBLICANS BACK IN CHARGE.
>> Laura: NEWT GINGRICH DID NOT
TAKE THE HOUSE BACK AFTER 50
YEARS OF GOP BEING LOCKED OUT OF
THE HOUSE BECAUSE OF THESE TIMES
OF VOTES.